citizens of the reject Nation it is time for
a Superman and not a man of steel not a man of
violence but a man of Tomorrow we're very excited
to dive into a I think beginning of the tomorrow
verse is that how this works that's right we
skipped ahead with long Halloween now we're
going to the start I like this I like this because
we're into several whole new universe we finished
the DC AMU and now we're at the beginning of the
tomorrow verse with the man of Tomorrow much like
Superman is starting James Gunn's Universe we are
starting the tomorrow first with this very excited
to get into it uh please do hit that notification
Bell hit that like button hit that comment board
saying like hey why'd you go back there what are
you doing this is what I want you to do and you
tell us what you want to do because we may do it
next it's all chaos who knows and much like the
man of tomorrow's wisdom and insight and macro
perspective of the world you know who else has
that the patron yes because much like Superman
they see it all they start at the beginning
they go to the end they experience every moment
including their resting face those are our resting
faces Superman's probably a little bit more stoic
but you get my point so become a patron if you
want to see the entirety of the experience
much like he does but first we are going
to watch react and review the man of Tomorrow
starting right now in three two foreign [Music]
there wasn't driving to start the
Batman one that's true but if the
tomorrow verse starts with driving I would
say that's a precedent yes so maybe the DC
AMU was drive heavy let's find out if the
overall tomorrow verse will be yeah yeah
snatched [Music]
a disappointment aliens are scary
aren't you glad they're not real
little on the nose jeez man thanks for calling
Deb it wasn't even that excuse it gets a little
jittery ah pause understanding man good man
paw he spends every waking minute trying to
get that thing to work he lifted a tractor with
one finger Martha he was gonna figure it out
whoever put him in that ship had no idea
or care for how dangerous a world they were
sending them to the more he knows the more he
can protect himself and US knowledge is power
when in doubt just try to slam it on the ground
that's uh that's how I saw my Rubik's Cube [Music]
now I really do have to get to work everyone's
counting on me I'm a big part of the team covering
today's launch you'll read about it tomorrow on
The Daily Planet I love you bye I signed an NBA
bye wait till let's follow here there you go you
kept my secret but you can't keep this one okay
oh spook
a latte no whip and I hope you don't mind
I had them add a dash of cinnamon to the
grinds it really wakes it up Superman off
coffees tomorrow and uh you don't actually
have to call me baby boy Kevin I would love
if this Superman was really just an expert on
coffee just knows because you can see the grind
he's like you know this could use genetically
you know I roasted these beans with my heat
they're about to launch the most sophisticated
store lips how you built that rocket with
other Hefty government contract this President
knows a good investment when he sees it does he
know fraud fraud who sees it not the question
I expected Lois your internship is over Lois
billion
oh no looks like you could use this more than
me oh Lifesaver cinnamon really wakes it up
cinnamon soups
boy it's gonna have to do
some Superman you got this
SpaceX it'll be fine it always
goes very well I've seen stuff
s our weapons
x-ray vision I'd say somebody already knows
we're not alone in the universe did just have
that hearing it was very it was something all
right sure did happen I protect my people I
think you're the one that might need protecting
two tours in Iraq I know a [__] I don't want
to see it yeah someone's interested in you kid I
Want You Back who are you R Jones yeah Rick Jones
is in Marvel but this man seems important like
are you gonna become another Hank Henshaw on me
clever it's a bird it's an exploding that's
our impending do oh no you gotta be kidding me
oh he's not in Superman at all yet wow
he's this guy with beanie yeah and goggles
let's go beanie goggle man yeah that's not the
same ring too but we're getting there
we're shopping it's all good [Music]
wow cool scope I'm loving this so far yeah that's
great this has been really solid also no full
origin but like a solid origin story yeah no yeah
you get the theme the Thematic qualities of it
feel the energy absorb it Neo freaking crooked
legs 15 years I would say hero after that rocket
event perhaps it's pretty obviously saved Millions
meet the newest addition to the team the grand
regret a billionaire genius
an actual talent low slang
it's a good way to boost morale and build a team
that's uh better than all you idiots will ever
be Lois by the way just Lois cool and you
are oh I'm coffee uh Clark I'm coffee boy
how did you do it people with that much power
think they wielded over everyone if you can take
that away from them for a moment you can take it
away for good any other questions if you're gonna
be a reporter kid you got to ask all the questions
what do you do now you've already taken down the
most powerful man in the world have I oh dedicated
life to taking down Superman now the Menace oh oh
I like her naming him in this yeah cool Cape that
name's not gonna stick as well the [Laughter]
love it that's delightful and put a
Big C on your chest for coffee boy
get a brown jacket an unidentified object
what do you know Brian Cranston tell us your
secrets Rick Jones Rick Jones oh what happened
to Mike Jones what did happen to Mike Jones leave
in the comments let us know what happened to Mike
Jones oh your cape my dude come back for it my
Kent's got to sell it for him yeah that's true
this is
holy [__] my man oh man why are you
are you Kryptonian of course I never heard
an old flying Kryptonian but what ifs
oh yeah
yes we're doing this the fun way yes
Superman is about fun Above All Else
gotta be mamawa it's just the momoaist character
or ever to Momoa yeah for a second I thought it
was his voice I was like what year is
this we're we're planning ahead yeah
electricals Electro leeches [Music]
woof this planet is protected alien
they ain't got mirrors on this dump
you're as alien as they come Round
Here Kryptonian I'm a Kryptonian
no last one in the universe tucked away in sector
2814. you got an awful big bounty on
that stupid looking head of yours oh
I guess that means you have to bring me
in alive Bounty Hunter names Lobo and no
of course no
no frag the [__] out of me you
know what you really wanted to say
wow
[Music]
oh cool I hope them pants hold on Clark
got Goblin glidered a little cool new take in the
origin making him like not know what he is until
the villain tells him and it makes sense someone
Cosmic like Lobo yeah someone with a bounty to
fill her perhaps he's trying to move the fight to
safer ground I mean that tracks with the modern
you know sensibilities I think he's going to be
Green Lantern oh I mean he kind of looks like him
yeah I think you're probably right right the
name threw me but everything else points to
he could have changed his name you never know
come on help him I wonder can you see in the dark
[Music]
parasite Maybe
I had good reach on that knee
ah we got a Dragon Ball Z
fighting her hands here folks
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
he's gonna keep making wild guesses
Martian manhunters that guy gay okay
okay but seeing how it was Krypton itself
killed your people carved from the remains
of that doomed Rock should be
the thing to mess you up oh no
for a second I was like is lobo Green
Lantern what a Twist what a weird choice
damn whoa
there's a lot going on yeah
how about this yeah it was
wow cool
[Music]
all right got a phase man
yes drink your solar berry juice
yes super booty Buns of Steel
[Music]
this was the fun way who needs a cape man
your Junk's been on TV now yeah this Cannon's
very different they uh they let your friends
stay naked throughout I wish I was so loved that
everyone's too busy to notice his face it'd be
great that's how the glasses work yeah it's
just dogs out the whole time it's the doctor
Manhattan Theory no one looks up because
I'm like whoa best disguise we got a little
it's never gonna catch on uh you took down
Luthor and now you're doing an expose on
the flying man I'm winning a Pulitzer
for my revelatory takedown of the alien
who calls himself the Superman no you
call him he's calling himself exactly
it's an interesting lowest take in this
movie edgy Lois they meet someone from the
stars and their first instinct is to fire
at will they love you they don't know me
you can either either meet it head
on and accept the consequences or
you can keep your head down and accept
the consequences but you have to make one
it's fair advice what the hell happened to
this guy I'm gonna close them back up no yep
no oh
oh absorb their life force parasite I've
come for your son sir unless you want
to show us some credentials I think we're
done here I'm sorry sorry whoa [Music] whoa
get inside lock the doors locked Gates
against this aliens yeah yeah [__] our
wooden door against a man faster
than me you another Bounty Hunter
yeah so cool yes I am no Bounty Hunter but I
am a man Hunter my name is John and I only wish
to speak with you why didn't you say so and look
this Superman believes him he doesn't just fight
for no reason it's almost like he's Superman oh
goodness what no koi when is he gonna level a
city court I mean faith in mankind who has it
or alien con Martian kind yeah drugs I'm sorry
without prescription I can't help you but there
is a clinic nearby where you can get detoxed oh
I love the colors of his little
yeah Power striations John is
good night love that her for attraction
a slipper party yep yeah why not it's
the first time I'm a martian guys there's
someone who friends with Clark he must stay
for breakfast when I first became aware that
your possess abilities similar to my own I
assumed pot you were Martian oh I attempted a
telepathic link between our minds and in doing
so I inadvertently accessed your memories
of Krypton you were only an infant oh yeah
oh nice I've never been
able to make this thing work
wow I love how important he is in this
Martian Manhunter being like the positive
to lobo's negative yeah is that your parents
but you should know that the last thing your
mother ever said to you was that to dwell in
the past to lose one's path so don't learn
anything about yourself mom's wishes how will
I find you just listen cool yeah what a great
Ambassador character and it suits them like it's
the perfect way to introduce them so what is it
I don't know some kind of historical record
you can do almost anything go anywhere only
oh you can go anywhere but as all those
photos posted all over the world show
your clothes can't yep
my kids respecting your dignity as your dong
splattered across every major newspaper has
proven mother I do not approve put your super
buns away you were swaddled in it when we oh
I met an old female in heat stop
stop what is wrong with you why
don't I show ya come on girlie oh yes
kryptonians the whole Army coming just
for him [__] don't care who they got
a little fighter get him sod just kidding
they're all dead you should have seen the
look on your face though damn she really
met her match and it's Lobo yeah Lobo
versus Lois let's do it and then I'll
give you a little bit of wham bam about
it really is half the Appalachian mating dance
or a young Michael Rooker sure God how great would
that be oh oh boy Whoa man
you're not looking so good
dude don't stop filming no
uh -huh [Music]
nice I love a good body withering gag I do like
the coloring too though it's really clever yeah
what have I done he's gonna have
moments of clarity I imagine yeah
whoa whoa
oh no
whoa what has he become
oh yeah you became the Cloverfield monster
yes he did this is the secret prequel
that's what it's exactly the kind
of thing Cloverfield would do
long game WB crossover WB bot slusho you know
this uh animated movie from like a decade or more
ago secretly a Cloverfield now you know oh he's
got the undies oh under Rose and the belt we're
overdue for That interview maybe when this is over
I'll be there no games I promise no power plays
oh yeah save us Tom Cruise it's a train yes
whoa
[Music]
laughs oh
yeah oh it looks like you're
cooking them how we doing John
he's learning oh wow
oh he is gonna be still wrong
looking a little doomsday there bud yeah
I was thinking that internally the interns
oh no no where are you John
oh boy I'm glad you have gloves oh
they don't help okay take it back
no please
no they didn't they didn't what they wouldn't he's
so good in this universe no wow save him
cold breath does he know he has Cobra no
wow the best Martian Manhunter we've had I
know he was great I'm legitimately bummed
they did the thing where they made them
great so they kill him make us feel things
but I don't like it because he's Jon Jones he
said like more screen time than the rest of
the movies combined and like greater impacts and
now he's oh why do they hate him so much foreign
interesting yeah I mean that absorption must
have Zapped a lot of his residual energy
it burned him alive Lois that parasite thing
I can still hear the screams and the Superman
I think he's dead too yeah see what you did with
your expose it's all your fault Lois this job take
smarter than you for help
I bet they're closer than you think you're
totally right perfect oh good great writing
I need your help I've seen you in action fly
boy you're as powerful as a locomotive more
[Music] I need to get into space the sun it's
like a power source for you isn't it and if you
need help getting closer to it that means you're
powerless that's why he's so smart he's just like
oh your son must be not not space itself how
much do you want no I don't want anything but
to help it can only look good to the parole board
sure but I can't help you from in here I have to
get out that's not going to happen Luthor I can
get a day pass that's not even a thing one a bet
you're a billionaire all the president make a
write me a Lex Luthor one time day pass it's just
a monopoly get out of jail card yes 24 hours I had
it notarized it's official all right there you go
fast I can't find my zombie oh
I worry about them now this is
gonna be fine dudes and everything goes
well everything yeah no it's totally oh
that looks different now hey let
me fix this bra Cloverfield monster
oh
this is from Star Labs how did you get this yep
that grenade was an organic EMP designed to
absorb all the power it comes in contact with
it's almost like it melded with the janitor's DNA
and turned him into some kind of energy vampire
wow it's like buying a company when you absorb
the assets you also absorb the vulnerabilities
if we can employ those we can defeat it
oh smart what are Superman's weaknesses
oh geez clever you might say I bought the
company Robo is now my asset or vulnerability
so good great use of Lex this plant Powers
the entire city where is everybody I called
in a bomb threat before we left you shouldn't lie
about bombs what if it saves many lives I didn't
[Music] my man
Zang
whoa nice
wowie Cloverfield freaking Kaiju
that helped him last time yeah man whoa
you can learn that power I was
gonna say I wonder if parasite
will help him learn some of his
latent Powers paying you to stand
around yeah yeah don't get your eyes
in a Twist who is his voice it's great
it's kind of sounds like I
feel like it can't be but
woof
Pacific Rim Lobo
oh my God no it looks like there's
a limit to how long the parasite can
retain your power and weakness
gotta let him absorb you again
what wow they're murking people in this tomorrow
versus like we're not here for a long time we're
here for a good time we're only here for like
five or six movies take a lot out in the beginning
oh boy oh boy no oh man what a well done shot just
line up so he can hit us all let him play
pool with us no she's just getting his gains
give him a weakness atta boy hey
want some more I'm right here eat me you
should get the ring first though yeah
[Music]
the definitive Godzilla oh no
I wonder if they have him no ah
I mean something's going on there
my prize
oh my God see here see here problem the
parasite is very powerful but the Superman
is also very powerful damn you yeah there
it is I'll just make you both my slaves
oh that's gonna hurt on the way down
oh yep yep
Lex Corp security issue pretty sweet
huh you had that thing made up fast
hey yes
redeemed I was getting real worried are
you all right put the parasite I saw it
kill you this is a comic book Kalel no
one dies you saw what I wanted it to see
uh someone did Drive yep I feel better about it
here we go finally cars the
true heroes of the DC Universe
what do you think you're gonna do oh
Lex Lois Lane live at the scene we're
on foot and we have a phone so we're live
streaming the military have tried to keep
the crowd back the family's always
on a car near the danger parasite
can absorb our strength knowledge
our feelings our Essence oh feelings
I know you're still in that room
tutti frutti oh Rudy you've gotten my
heart my love for my family and friends
Rudy you're a combat veteran who served with honor
Rudy proud father one in first grade Kaylee
right and another on the way oh my parents
Hope was that they had sent me to a world where
I would be safe and protected but the price of
that protection Silence about who and what I
really am good zoom on that I was scared but
I'm not scared anymore my name is calell of
Krypton and I come in peace and I am Iron Man
oh no Rudy still available Rudy come
on oh oh he just wants to see them Rudy
no no no no no no no no no no no you are human no
no no no no no no
no no
oh no think altruistic thoughts yeah
right think about your family oh God
oh God uh oh oh no I wonder if he
has to absorb it then he just like
over I don't know I don't know what's
gonna happen I love that I don't know
altruistic parasite wow find the Good
Will of Superman great scope shot
[Music]
tell you what metropolis's
electric Bill's gonna go Skyrocket
whoa this is gonna be gooey
[Music]
oh calcified
I kind of love that even Superman and Jon Jones
combined couldn't take out parasite wow I'll be
ours Dust in the Wind you could have mentioned the
immortality I like to keep people guessing sure
we bought it yeah aliens the last surviving
members of each of our peoples two capes so
I killed all my people people self
it's what do I give a [__] so my
origin is technically different nah ah just
kidding you should have seen your face though
I love him I love him so much you know those are
just stories right every rat bastard I hunt is the
last of his people something you say to keep the
Bounty hot are you saying there are other martians
out there hell yeah seen him myself might even be
a Kryptonian or two yeah there might oh it might
be a carazarel out there who knows you should
go follow him find your people and you Kalel
it's Superman my people are right here oh
you couldn't meet me over by the stairs
or losing valuable interview
time sorry Miss Lane not today
power play power play Superman Our Man Of Tomorrow
nice uh you know what I told you about power moves
Clark well I was right they really do work has
anybody seen my calendar [Music] [Applause]
that's George [Applause] [Music]
Ah that's my Superman I really enjoyed that from
the jump that's my Superman I loved that that was
delightful and lovely and well orchestrated
all around and everyone complaining online
that you can only have a Superman movie with
just Superman to start well look what we did
oh well yeah it's like that felt like a
Superman movie it felt like it set the
character up obviously but it also wasn't
Ensemble you got a couple other powers I
feel like they were stealing Focus or
you know diluting things Darren Chris
could not play some Ryan Hurst is lobo okay
that tracks that's great Alexandra Daddario
man okay good voice that's wonderful
and like not the you know go-to everyone
thinks of blank like Ryan Hurst is usually
Thor in my head or Sons of Anarchy sure no
yeah I really like the voice cast across the
board in this and I mean we've talked about
you know just different takes on the characters
and whatnot and uh and we've spent a lot of time
with who was that like Jerry O'Connell or was uh
Superman in the AMU but um but yeah no I mean I
really liked the way they personified pretty
much everybody and I mean even like I wonder
how this the Clark and Lois relationship
will develop over the tomorrow verse yeah
um because that's that's the thing is like you
know that feels still very much like it's at
the beginning of their story yeah yeah yeah and I
mean I still like there's a certain amount like I
don't know exactly what the definitive yeah I know
Lois Lane to be like a spunky character certainly
like a hard-hitting journalist obviously but uh
you know she had like kind of a you know like an
edge in this movie but that is also kind of you
know being opened to the benevolence yeah she's
always been like I'll do anything for the story
but never hurt anybody and that it's kind of fun
to see you know a go-getter Lois Lane separate
of Clark in the beginning and I also love that
they're doing An Origin that doesn't feel like an
origin which I always love when they can do but
also that everyone kind of has their arcs like
everyone grows through the movie like everyone
changes a bit and and that was like 10 lead
characters that was really well done and also
Superman starts as Superman like this is how
I love to see Superman he's so altruistic he's
so you know his his humor comes from being just
so wholesome and good he didn't feel overpowered
which is really impressive to do an origin movie
where Superman doesn't feel op one I like that the
ultimate there is a lot of fighting but it's not
the ultimate solution is we just had to you know
fight the [__] out of this yeah and I liked it
as much as they they clearly you know a parasite
is a is it already existing character as well
but it seems like they don't seem a lot but it
seems like yeah they took that character and then
combined elements of the Doomsday plot because
you know he's absorbing like part of his link to
Superman is the key to defeating doomsday but then
that's not even the actual solution here you know
it's and it's a sacrifice it's an appeal I thought
that was such a great choice to have it be like
oh not only do you absorb the power you absorb
the vulnerability and you absorb the heart the the
disposition of who you've just taken on and that
leads to the key and yeah it's not a perfect rap
round like oh he gets to have his family back but
he does make a sacrifice you know with that last
Moment of clarity for his family yeah 2020 so this
is pretty recent okay sure uh I also really like
that this was a Superman movie like you mentioned
parasite but this didn't have doomsday didn't
have Lex is the big bad didn't have like it
wasn't your usual suspects but it uses The Usual
Suspects well like Lex is definitely nefarious in
a douche nozzle and like you definitely have
uh really wonderful characterization of all
these these characters that you can grow with but
also Superman didn't just punch his way to solve
it like Superman didn't defeat him no like this
was so good like this was a great yeah this was
a great like sort of first few days on the job
kind of story for me and I loved you know the
way they did man paw I loved the little prologue
I love the way that they're watching the a alien
movie and there are themes that tie around both
for Cal but also for Martian Manhunter for uh John
in this movie and even I mean like lobo's such a
boisterous character but even he you know has some
kind of overlapping commonality with them being
that he is an alien uh and I loved just like the
the continuing reversals with him the whole you
know you should just eat your face and I really
liked that there was a uh negative alien influence
and a positive alien influence for Clark I really
liked that there was a mentor in in John and
then there was like the the Lobo hunting him and
how you've got like the different uh pressures
of being someone discovering your powers with
aliens and how much he has to absorb and just
deal with but he's Clark so he's navigating it
like that was great yeah and I mean seeing him
like I love the uh the preliminary suit with
just like the bomber jacket and the beanie yeah
and the way the people need to sort of acclimate
and come around to and sort of they have all
these questions about like well you know it
seems like he's here to help us but is he really
here to help purpose and the whole like power play
thing coming full circle like this is this was
so rich man and 2020 means like you know this
is all really recent and we've got a bunch more
I I the animation wasn't quite as Rich um there
were a couple moments where I definitely noticed
they had to like creatively Zoom or crop and like
did you know some interesting stuff but overall I
preferred this take on Superman I'm really excited
to see these origins of you know characters I love
in this new world like that there's some really
intriguing options to go from here yeah absolutely
like I thought this was like earlier than it was
but yeah 2020 like just happened yeah and and yeah
what a great sort of it does have that archery
thing like the the animation at times does remind
me a little bit of Archer but I do love their
establishing shots like I love their Metropolis
design I loved A lot of the stuff in Smallville
just like the I thought they were still able to
ring a good amount of tone or like you know that
one shot where parasite is turning to go to the
big reactor yeah you get that like Pacific Rims oh
cool like I found the the way they used time for
him like being slow and then the leap that was so
fun yeah totally like and there are a lot of you
know obviously little cheeky superman-esque nods
but yeah it's like even if the animation I feel
like animation over time has certainly become a
medium sort of affected by like well we can't
dump as much money into this as we used to so
yeah it's like I'm I'm willing to be forgiving of
those same things and I think that that this is an
example of a movie where despite some of those
like you know budget constraints I still think
like the conception of so many of the images and
uh and the mood of so many of the other in that
so many of the images really translates and most
of all I can't shake the fact that you know we're
getting a Superman movie live action that's going
to be introducing us to a New Lex a new Lois a new
Jimmy but also we just found out a Mr terrific
a uh you know Guy Gardner uh Green Lantern a
um who else did they announce for sure for sure
hot girl and metamorpho yeah so that's a lot and
that can be done this was 90 minutes this was very
short and they did a lot of World building and
they did a lot of establishing and it didn't feel
rushed and didn't feel like they lost Superman to
that it felt like a world was already formed
which is one of the strengths of the DC to me
is like we're gonna have a fully formed DCU yeah
absolutely and I mean I think there's a Justice
Society movie in the in the continuity after this
one but I love it yeah a little you get like a
little reference to Batman who then we'll see in
the long Halloween and then you get yeah it's like
it's got enough super characters and things in the
foreground and then enough sort of things to hint
that the world is bigger without forcing it to
go all those places in the first installment yeah
like yeah this is establishes so lovely and yeah
it draws so many nice little like Inspirations
from across the pantheon I would imagine and
uh and yeah manages to do it while feeling I I
I think I like four stars for me yeah absolutely
and I and I love the origin also that yeah he's
discovering stuff he doesn't have all the memories
Ma and PAW don't have the means to get his full
story uh John helps him with a little uh codex
you know pyramid thingy like oh I love that I love
that amazingness he's got like a mentor love that
John didn't die in a you know well Jonathan didn't
die in a tornado accident he gets to stick around
a little while I had a really interesting moment
when I I uh there was a rumor going around that
Brendan Fraser might be pocket and one perfect I
mean I would love that two Redemption for Batgirl
three uh my most interesting take was a lot of
people were like yeah but pocket dies and I was
like huh the average person thinks of poquette as
a dead character as I think of him as living like
to me Superman can always fly over to Kansas and
visit mompaw Kent and uh because of Smallville and
the Snyder World though those only two continues
I think of pot Kent is dying that young like Paul
Kent does eventually die in the comics but he's in
the comics for decades okay yeah and like he's
in the comics right now like he's alive in the
comics right now so like I would keep Brennan
Frazier alive but I I think the average viewer
knows the biggest TV Universe at Smallville and
the biggest movie universe as Snyder they don't
think about Ken is alive well and maybe in a
visual media it's an easy I feel like there's
an emotional easy emotional trauma choice to be
like my mentor my father he's dead now you know
keep him alive keep hot Kent alive this time James
again and they're gonna make us trauma enough that
he's gonna make us cry some animals gonna get hurt
no no yeah if anybody I think it can ring the uh
the the more nuanced version of you know like
what if we meet Superman with crypto oh my God
because James Gunn loves animals what yes crypto's
on the on the ship with him oh my crypto dude yeah
that's sent to be your protector dude if we get
crypto Ace like another animal I mean obviously
detective chimp detective chips and then Super
Pets 2 happens because that movie was surprisingly
great uh but yeah this was delightful I I really
really had a good time with that love this uh well
lovelies uh we are now in the tomorrow verse I
do believe our plan it could change but our plan
will be to dive into it looks like Justice Society
World War and that'll connect us right to the long
Halloween which we've already watched so check out
the long Halloween videos part one and two uh we
want to get you guys to see this whole tomorrow
verse with us and remember if you want us to keep
doing these please do like subscribe notification
Bell share post us on forums tell your friends
tell your family tell your dad who loves Superman
hey there's this great movie and these guys you
don't know are watching it you just watch it with
them and they'll be like that's crazy it's a weird
thing to do also be a patron so you'd be like hey
let's watch them pause and think about their where
they've been and what they've become please do
check all those out and uh we want to keep doing
these so check out the whole playlist we're gonna
keep diving through and next up should be Justice
Society anything last uh say to the folks no just
a more naked Superman steel more Buns of Steel and
who else had butts of parasites parasites or Buns
of Steel and parasitic butts coming soon to the
Tamara verse maybe after long Halloween we get
some bat butts you know who's got the greatest
glutes in the entire DC Universe Nightwing
oh sure oh cannons no it's actually like a
running joke no Nightwing literally like covers
are drawn of him with that but that badonkadonk
but it's about the other side he's the
one hero who only does legs he is a man
of scarves whatever he's like I got these
two batons but they're really waited for
my squat game because Nightwing he wields
some gray Suns if you know what I'm saying
uh all right that is gonna do it for this
episode of koi likes Nightwing's butt and
we will see you next time it's a great
butt super good butt much love y'all
thank you